want to get through this
[Music]
I've never seen Tom Hardy's lips still
waiting for the day we see Tom Hardy's
lips the new Mad Max movie is opening
this weekend and some are saying it
might be the greatest action movie ever
others are calling it feminist
propaganda I'm on Laurie and I'm here to
set the record straight
this is hashtag news
[Music]
the movie is directed by George Miller
who made the first Mad Max trilogy and
also babe pig in the city which features
equally impressive stunt work movie
starts Tom Hardy as angry Maxwell and
Charlize Theron as furiosa a warrior
with a shaved head and a badass robot
arm and apparently Charlize even though
she's been presented as more of a
supporting character by the marketing
for the movie is actually the real star
of it and a lot of people are calling
the movie an extremely feminist story in
disguise so they're upset because they
think it is some sort of feminist
propaganda rolled up into an action
movie so for our answer we turn to es
ler writer of The Vagina Monologues who
was brought on to help write some of the
female sex slave characters in the movie
Ensor says yep it is a feminist action
movie just because Mad Max has badass
female characters does not mean it's not
going to be the most awesome action
movie this year the reviews are amazing
it got 99 percent on Rotten Tomatoes and
critics are just showering it with
praise it's so clean with praise Vince
Mancini of film drunk said it might be
the best action movie of the last ten
years Jeff Baker of The Oregonian wrote
in his review but it sets new standards
in old-school stunt work and car chases
and doesn't in service of an idea driven
story with a beating heart an idear
driven story with a beating heart that
just happen to have a feminist message
it's essentially a two-hour car chase
that doesn't let up if you've seen the
original movies critics are not only
saying that it's better than them but
that it's the rare reboot that moves the
concept forward and the antithesis of
the world-building superhero movies that
are playing in every other theater and
the multiplex right now but if men's
rights activists who are actually
calling for a boycott of the film
because they think it's feminist
propaganda want to deny themselves the
best action movie of the last 10 years
I'm gonna let him as for the complaints
that Mad Max doesn't feel like the lead
in his own movie this isn't new to the
series both the road warrior and Beyond
Thunderdome have max coming into
communities and helping them solve their
problems and only saying like 10 lines
it's not a new thing he was never much
of a talker more of a really intense
not great on the phone is what I'm
saying Mad Max has a cast with a lot of
women which is unique right now for
popcorn movies in light of all the talk
about Black Widow and Marvel's alleged
misogyny problem
not to mention Hollywood's in general
but we'll have to see for ourselves this
weekend if Mad Max really is the queen
of action movies let us know what you
think is it gonna be the best action
movie of this year you've already seen
it comment no spoilers
also subscribe why not there's gonna be
more of this more Mad Max Tom Hardy we
love Tom Hardy I love Tom Hardy Tom
Hardy if you're watching please
subscribe I'm onna lorry and uh-huh
that's my Tom Hardy impression I just
told you my credit card info so good
luck
[Music]